what makes a great story Wow that's a
that's a great question that's a very
big broad question what makes a great
story to me where it starts is a really
compelling problem that is going to take
the whole story to be solved that
millions of strangers consuming that
story would be able to identify with
this problem and care that it gets
solved and be really entertained by the
process of watching people try to solve
it so that's kind of a lot of things in
one but to me that's kind of where it
all starts with there's something that
someone's going through in life that
really matters to them and hopefully to
us as the audience it's really important
it's really difficult it's going to take
a lot of effort and active action toward
trying to solve it which isn't going to
work
so it's difficult it's complicated
trying to solve it usually leads to
pushback and complications and things
that don't go as planned
and so that tends to build the sense of
problematic situations so it's growing
and escalating Oh building over the
course of the story and then in the end
there's some kind of resolution that has
taken the audience on a journey and
usually taken certain characters on a
journey where they're not the same as
what they were and therefore it was
meaningful and important in some way
that they went through that how does
someone know their movie idea sucks well
most of us don't know it's hard to know
without getting third party objective
feedback from someone who isn't just
your friend who's gonna try to encourage
you it can help to put it in a so-called
drawer for a couple of months we don't
really have literal drawers anymore
where we put printed out screenplays but
I certainly will write a draft or even a
few drafts until I feel pretty good
about something and then I'll put it
away and work on something else for you
know two or three months and then when I
come back to it I have a much better
objective sense of what works and
doesn't work then I had when I was
finishing that draft so getting that
objectivity that perspective that's
outside the perspective of the writer
who's just trying to make it
work but the evaluator who's just seeing
it for the first time and finding fault
with it is hard to do and it can help to
have those sort of built-in delays
between you writing it and then you
looking at it again and of course other
people can give you that perspective as
well but you know all you can really do
is say well here are the principles of
what makes something good and here's
what I think is good and here's what I'm
trying to do that I think is good and
here's me doing it to the best of my
ability but I think you always end up
with something that you're like people
may all think this sucks I may not have
anybody that likes this or at least the
right people aren't gonna like this
that's always very possible and I
certainly go through that with
everything I've ever written things that
people loved and things that people
didn't love I had that same insecurity
and I remember feeling feeling
encouraged when I read I think it was
John Steinbeck like some journal entry
like before I want to say before Grapes
of Wrath where he was so insecure about
what he was writing it's not gonna live
up to the success he had on some other
thing and he would talk about what he
was writing about and why it just wasn't
working and no one's gonna like it and
so it's kind of like a built-in
insecurity that you have I mean maybe
some people don't have it maybe some
people think everything they write is
great but in my experience the people
that are the that do the best usually
have a pretty highly developed
self-critical Sensibility maybe to their
detriment maybe it goes too far to where
you don't trust in any of your stuff
being a value so but but you can go too
far in either direction you don't really
know if it sucks you just suspect it
might suck or you're worried people are
gonna say that it does so in the end
like all you can really do is learn the
principles you know learn and study to
understand what makes things work and
then try to please yourself try to write
something you would really want to see
so that something that fulfills the
things that you most loved and then get
that objective perspective however you
can and and and then hope for the best
cuz you never really know you know what
other people are gonna say if that's
where I was going with that and then you
you you said it before I was even able
to
go there and that is do you find most
writers or the of the camp that they
they're so critical of their own work or
are they of the equally detrimental camp
which is everything they do is amazing
and the world's just waiting for that
can be just as damaging yeah more
damaging I think yeah yeah yeah I think
I think most writers who've been doing
it for a while
tend to be more in the camp of wow this
is hard and I like what I'm writing sort
of for a while but I'm nervous that
people aren't gonna like it and I and I
may be very self-critical I think when
you're first starting out and you write
your first couple of things and no one's
bashed your head in yet with negative
feedback you tend to be more naive and
be more like oh this is fun and this is
good what I've written hey everybody
look at what I wrote and then when you
get actual like aggressively negative
professional level objective feedback
it's like I remember the first time I
got that I was still living in Ohio
where I grew up and I've written like
one screenplay in college you know I was
a film production major and I was like
wrote my second one and I knew somebody
who knew somebody who was a major
Hollywood producer and they were willing
to send my script to that producer and
after many months the script got sent
back to me with coverage that that
producers reader had written like a
two-page coverage where they tore my
script apart so violently about how just
terrible it was that it was really
shocking and and obviously demoralizing
for a while and that was my first taste
of you can write something that you
think's really good and and when you
send to the people that really quote
matter that could help move it forward
they're not going to give you any of the
Bennett for the doubt that your friends
are going to give you they're really
looking out like a business is this
product a worthy product that I'm gonna
put money and time behind or not and
they're if they don't think so they're
gonna be or if they have to tell their
boss whether it is or not they're gonna
be pretty you know pretty clear and
about why it isn't and most of the time
they think it isn't and most of time
those scripts aren't something that this
big producer
to speak would actually be able to do
something with that's just the reality
of the world
so once you've been been beaten down a
little bit by having that happen a few
times I think you tend to be more
self-critical and and obviously I can go
too far to where you're then too down on
yourself or too unsure not confident
enough in what you're doing and also too
you could be you could come off some hit
and there's people waiting in the wings
critics well-established critics that
are just looking for blood in the water
sort I mean that's a real you know
unfortunate part of the industry there
are people just waiting for the next hit
of somebody to have an opinion and then
they're able to promote their piece
based on you know their dislike of
something that the public loves and
having to face the ramifications of that
we know many careers that have probably
been halted for a little while off of
that yeah I mean what it could also
happen is if you've been told you're the
greatest for long enough you can feel
that it's - that it's really easy to
write something that will be successful
maybe you're already very successful and
some other related part of filmmaking
and and now you're writing and then you
know and no one is telling you no you
know and so you can you can having too
much encouragement I mean it's like a
double-edge thing it's like you want
encouragement helpful because most of us
really thrive on and need some by the
same time if all you get is
encouragement that's not really honest
encouragement it can obviously make you
unaware of you know some of the flaws of
what you're doing or you know keep you
from being as as critical or have as
much you know objective perspective on
your work is it might need yeah the
golden child syndrome yeah I mean no no
no if that's a real designation but yeah
that would be equally viable we know a
lot of people whose downfall has been
from that as well yeah yeah so is there
a happy medium is it can you be do you
think that just takes time so wherever
the pendulum has swung and you fall
under that after you've kind of been
beaten down a little bit that's where
the real magic happens is after you kind
of take a real stock of yourself and
your work
or do some people never self-correct
some people just go into a hole to me
it's more like with so many things it's
like a daily challenge it's a daily
challenge to have the right mindset and
the right attitude toward what you're
doing it's not a thing that you arrive
at suddenly a perfect place where you're
emotionally healthy and you know how to
like view your work in the most sort of
you know critical enough but not too
critical kind of way I think it's more
just like everyday there's a tendency to
hate what you wrote that day or to think
what you wrote that day's genius right
and so it's just a constant practice of
being kind of almost a zen about it not
let the highs get to higher the lows get
to low not be too down yourself or too
in love with everything you've ever done
either but just be kind of like I'm just
it's like a practice like a spiritual
practice I'm practicing it writing I'm
writing every day and a big part of
writing is practicing the consciousness
that works the best to be writing and
producing stuff that you feel you know
decent about and that consciousness is
kind of like letting go of opinions even
your own opinion to some extent at a
certain point and letting go of ego and
just be trying to like invite and allow
ideas and explore ideas and a kind of a
playful way knowing that there will be
time later for the critical mind to come
in and hash through all of it but that
critical mind can really strangle the
creative process when what you need most
of the time is more ideas not more
criticism so but for me that's a daily
challenge to not get too critical or you
know and or not get too overly confident
to the point of you know not putting
something through the rigors of the
creative process of rewriting and so
forth but to just be like present in the
creative ideas state and then critical
wanting to be critical but not too
critical I don't feel like I'll ever get
to a place where I've got that also
handled and I'm just great at that it's
like I have to work at it daily
you